dans cette usine ligne de gaz près de
tunis
le ballet des camions citerne est
incessant à son bord de l'oxygène à
destination des hôpitaux du pays
la vraie consommation de l'oxygène on
l'a vue venir avec la deuxième vague qui
est arrivé vers la fin du mois de
septembre et nous on a vu une
augmentation exponentielle à partir du
mois d'octobre jusqu'à arriver à un pic
de demande vers le milf et vrilles et la
demande
elle a augmenté quatre fois par rapport
à la demande normale la demande est
telle que les besoins en oxygène ont
dépassé les capacités de production de
la tunisie sans milite sont produits
chaque jour dans le pays
seulement voilà les hôpitaux et
cliniques ont actuellement besoin de 170
mille litres pour combler le manque
tunis a donc dû importer d'europe et
d'algérie plus récemment trouvé les
70000 etrm encore représente donc un
défi quotidien
d'autant que les besoins journaliers
pourrait bientôt atteindre 200
millilitres
aujourd'hui les prévisions de
consommation future sont de l'ordre de
deux fois la production locale
donc c'est clair qu'on dépend d'eux au
même temps de la production locale ainsi
que des emplois des importations et on
n'est jamais à l'abri d'un petit souci
qui une machine qui s'arrête ou bien un
bateau qui va à cause du mauvais temps
ne pas arriver à l'heure
une demande en oxygène symbole d'une
situation sanitaire qui se dégrade
depuis plusieurs semaines bien que
réticent imposer de nouvelles
restrictions en pleine crise sociale le
gouvernement a finalement décidé
vendredi d'imposer un nouveau
confinement d'une semaine la situation
épidémique actuel est qualifié de
situation grave grave et sévère grave
parce que les indicateurs sont un petit
peu tous au rouge
le taux de positivité des examens reste
élevé aux alentours de 30% le nombre de
malades en réanimation et donc les
leaders et à sang pratiquement saturé
les ni le nombre de malades aussi
vont-ils et est en constante
augmentation
sans compter des du nombre de malades
qui existe dans les services d'urgences
qui sont en attente de les deux red
nation
du côté de la vaccination lancée à la mi
mars elle connaît depuis un certain
ralentissement en raison de la
difficulté à s'approvisionner en doses
et de dysfonctionnements sur la
plateforme gouvernementale seulement
plus de trois cent trente mille
personnes ont reçu au moins une dose en
deux mois -2 3% de la population